Transcription: Emily Hinz
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
J'avais préparé cette présentation
de façon très élaborée.
J'avais écrit un texte
et j'avais fait passer ce texte
par un réviseur professionnel
pour que je puisse me présenter
et vous présenter
mes idées en parlant
un français impeccable.
Mais à la fin, quand je réfléchissais
ce matin sur le thème de cette conférence
et on y a pour parler
des langages des idées
c'est-à-dire, ID, les deux lettres
notre identité,
mais aussi nos idées,
ce qu'on a dans la tête.
Je me suis décidé à la fin de ne pas
suivre ce que j'avais préparé.
Donc, j'ai pris la décision de jeter
toutes ces feuilles que j'avais préparées
et de me présenter aujourd'hui
comme je suis.
Avec toutes mes failles, toutes mes fautes
et quelques vertus aussi.
Alors, ça nous pose un problème
à vous et à moi
parce que je ne parle pas
rigoureusement le français.
Alors, je m'explique.
C'est vrai que comme interprète
je ne parle pas mal de langues
y compris le français.
Mais les interprètes font une
catégorisation très spéciale de langues.
On parle des langues
« A », « B » et « C ».
Et le français est, pour moi,
ce qu'on appelle une langue passive.
Une langue « C ».
C'est-à-dire une langue depuis laquelle
je suis prêt à interpréter.
Je suis très capable de le faire.
Mais vers laquelle je n’interprète jamais
parce que je n'ai pas une maîtrise
complète de cette langue.
Donc, au cours de cette présentation,
je vais vous dire des bêtises,
ça c'est assuré, ok ?
Je ferai les fautes et si c'est le cas -
et je peux vous assurer
que ça sera le cas -
je vous prie de bien en prendre notes
et à le fin, m'envoyer peut-être
un courriel pour me tirer l'oreille
et sur base de ça, on avance,
c'est bien ?
Ok, donc avec ça, on commence !
Regardez bien cette photo-là.
Elle était prise à Brasília
le 17 mars 1992,
c'était un mardi.
Elle marque aussi le moment précis
où je suis devenu interprète.
Mais permettez-moi de revenir
en arrière pour vous raconter
comment j'en suis arrivé là.
Quatre ans auparavant,
j'entrais à l'assemblée nationale
du Brésil en tant qu'employé.
Je m'ennuyais ferme à noircir
du papier huit heures par jour.
Ce jour-là, à la dernière minute,
quelqu'un s'est rendu compte
qu'à la fin le prince
ne parlait pas portugais
et qu'il fallait trouver quelqu'un qui
pourrait faire le médiation linguistique.
J'étais vraiment ennuyé du job
que je faisais à l'époque
et j'avais fait courir le bruit
que je parlais couramment anglais.
À un certain moment,
j'ai reçu un coup de fil
deux heures après j'étais assis
sur cette chaise-là
pour faire cette médiation.
Le monsieur en costume clair,
il s'appelle Ibsen Pinheiro
il était à l'occasion
le président de l'assemblée nationale.
En face de lui, de manière oblique,
vous trouvez Son Altesse Royale,
le Prince Philippe,
duc d'Édimbourg.
Et le jeune homme entre eux,
celui-là avec plein de cheveux, c'est moi.
(Rires)
Voilà, donc, c'est ainsi qu'a commencé
ma carrière d'interprète.
Quelques semaines après, je me trouvais
en face de la princesse de Thaïlande.
Et quelque mois plus tard,
on m'a poussé dans l'eau, on dirait,
je nageais, à ma grande surprise.
Et j'ai aussi eu l'occasion de faire
la médiation de pas mal d'ambassadeurs
qui venaient présenter leur lettre
de créance et tout ça
et aussi quelques Chefs d'État
y compris le Dalaï Lama
et aussi le monsieur au milieu
qui s'appelle Michel Temer
qui, après quelques années,
est devenu le président du Brésil.
C'est ça qui m'est m'arrivé
et c'est ainsi que je suis devenu
l’interprète attitré
de l'assemblée nationale
et du président d'assemblée nationale
qui à l'occasion était aussi
le Vice-président de la République
suite à la chute du président Collor.
J'ai fini par quitter mon job au congrès
et j'ai ouvert à certain moment
un agence de traduction
que j'ai gardée pendant dix sept ans
qui s’appelait « Die Presse »
comme le journal autrichien.
Quelques années après,
j'étais déjà un interprète très bien formé
et j'ai décidé à aller aux États-Unis
pour suivre une formation académique.
Et j'ai pris quelques années
pour faire un master
à l'institution Monterey en Californie.
Et après une dizaine d'années,
j'ai été nommé le chef interprète
de l'ITU à Genève,
une agence spécialisée de l'ONU.
Donc peu à peu, j'ai commencé à avancer
et c'est ça qui a fait de moi
un interprète plus ou moins compétent.
Si vous [observez bien],
vous remarquez peut-être Barack Obama
qui est au fond de cette photo-là.
Voilà, on avance.
Vu de l'extérieur,
l'interprétation simultanée
s'apparente à de la magie.
De l'intérieur, c'est de la folie pure.
Vous passez votre vie
dans une cabine étouffante
avec des collègues qu'on connaît
très bien normalement
et on est obligé de répéter
dans une langue différente
des idées et des mots des autres gens
qu'on ne connaît pas de tout.
En gardant le rythme,
le ton, l'intention, le sens
et au même temps en cherchant
des mots et des documents
tout en continuant d’interpréter.
Il nous faut aussi faire
une sorte de dialogue silencieux
avec le collègue du jour
au moindre geste, regard,
de notes pour qu'on puisse s'en sortir.
Pour empirer la situation,
on est normalement au bout de la salle,
de l'autre côté de la salle,
normalement ici,
dans des cabines comme celles-là
et on ne peut pas faire signe à l'orateur
de ralentir, de l’interrompre,
ou de faire des éclaircissements,
et tout ça.
Face à tant d'obstacles,
on pourrait penser que l'interprétation
simultanée est une chose impossible.
Pourtant, elle est parfaitement faisable.
C'est vraiment un beau métier,
c'est un boulot extraordinaire.
Ça m'a donné l'occasion
d'aller partout dans le monde.
Ça m'a posé au côtés des gens
vraiment importants.
Et ça m'a donné, de mon propre voix,
l'opportunité de dire des choses
très impactantes, qui ont fait l'histoire.
J'ai eu l'occasion peut-être de lire
dans le journal le lendemain d'une réunion
exactement la phrase
que j'avais prononcée dans ma langue.
Ce n'est pas la phrase
que le président avait dit
parce qu'il parlait une langue différente.
Donc, il y a des trucs
parfois très intéressants.
Donc on est là vraiment
pour faire l'histoire
et on en fait partie, c'est bien.
Mais c'est aussi un boulot qui est parfois
la source de beaucoup de frustration.
Surtout la frustration de passer
toute une vie professionnelle
en exprimant les idées des autres.
On utilise notre voix, nos gestes,
tout ce qu'on a pour bien communiquer
non pas pour exprimer
ce qu'on sent et ce qu'on veut dire,
mais par contre, pour le faire
pour les autres personnes.
Il a y a aussi ce faux sentiment
d'appartenance
parce que aujourd'hui je suis là
juste à côté du président
et des autres membres aussi, avec le roi,
mais une fois que la lumière s’éteint,
je suis juste l’interprète.
Et ça nous casse parfois
un petit peu la tête.
Il y a des collègues
qui certainement ont eu des difficultés
à considérer cet aspect
de notre profession.
Donc, à un certain moment on commence
à se poser la question : pourquoi ?
Pourquoi s'y consacrer ?
Pourquoi faire ce boulot
plein de difficultés ?
Pourquoi passer toute sa vie
de cette manière compliquée
qui nous empêche
de nous exprimer et tout ça ?
Et à un certain moment, on commence
à sentir un niveau d'angoisse
qui monte mais on ne sait pas
exactement pourquoi.
En même temps qu'on devient
un meilleur interprète
plus compètent et tout ça,
en même temps, au moins à moi,
je ressentais constamment
ce sentiment de n'est pas vraiment y être.
Comme si j'étais juste une voix invisible
et que j'étais, quand-même -
je n'étais pas épanoui.
Donc à un certain moment,
j'ai commencé à me poser la question :
pourquoi est-ce que je me sens comme ça ?
Pourquoi l’anxiété ?
Je fais ça depuis des années,
pourquoi et pourquoi ?
Et donc j'étais à ce point-là,
un interprète très peu sûr de moi.
Et ça me gênais.
Donc j'ai commencé à me poser
la question : pourquoi ?
En portugais, le mot « pourquoi »
est une question mais aussi un réponse.
On utilise le même mot,
ce n'est pas comme en français
qu'on dit « pourquoi » et « parce que ».
En portugais on dirait « por que »
et la réponse est aussi « porque ».
On l'écrit de manière
légèrement différente.
À un certain moment,
je me suis rendu compte
que « pourquoi » est aussi peut-être
la meilleure réponse
et pas juste la meilleure question.
C'est une leçon que j'ai apprise
d'un autre interprète,
un interprète très célèbre,
mais d'un genre différent.
Il s'appelle Vido Santiago.
Et si son nom ne vous dit rien,
le temps est venu peut-être
de bien connaître Vido.
C'est un saxophoniste virtuose
et il a parcouru le monde entier
pour souffler dans son saxophone.
Il a joué avec tous les chanteurs
et toutes les chanteuses
de la scène internationale.
Il a été invité par tous les festivals
de jazz de la planète.
On est très proche parce que j'ai épousé
sa sœur il y a une trentaine d'années.
(Rires)
Donc, un beau jour,
j'étais à la maison de ma belle-mère
et on a commencé à parler.
Je lui ai demandé :
« Vido, tu te présentes souvent
devant de milliers de personnes,
comment est-ce que tu fais pour gérer
les tracs, est-ce que ça t'arrive ? »
Il m'a dit: « Non, ça ne m'arrive pas.
Mais je suis en rituel très strict ».
Il a commencé à me raconter
tout ce qu'il faisait
et à la fin il m'a dit que chaque fois
avant de monter sur scène,
il prenait une minute pour bien réfléchir,
pour faire une sorte
de méditation et tout ça
et pour bien prier.
Et pour moi, c'était une vraie surprise
qu'après tant d'années de tourner
quelqu'un comme Vido
suivait cette routine,
avec besoin de le faire.
Et je continuait de lui poser
la question : mais pourquoi
et comment fait-on pour en sortir ?
Il m'a dit :
« Une fois que tu connais la raison
pour laquelle tu fais quelque chose,
l’anxiété va disparaître.
Ça disparaît complètement.
Il faut te poser la question. »
Et après, il a commencé
à me donner des exemples.
Il m'a donné quatre exemples.
Il a dit : « Parmi les musiciens,
il y a certains collègues
qui jouent depuis un émotion de colère.
Ils sont fâchés
parce qu'ils sont discriminés,
que ce soit par racisme,
ou sexuellement ou à cause de leur âge,
ou quoi que ça soit.
Et donc, quand ils montent sur scène,
ils portent avec eux cette colère
et ils utilisent cette émotion pour
prendre leur revanche contre le monde.
Et le résultat est
de la bonne musique quand même.
Il y a aussi quelques collègues
qui le font depuis d'un émotion de vanité.
Ils ont un grade d'insécurité assez grand
qui les obligent à monter sur scène,
et faire de leur mieux,
pour que à la fin, ils reçoivent
des applaudissements
et leur confiance en eux vient avec ça.
Il y a aussi quelques autres qui
jouent parce que ils aperçoivent
que, en fait, ils devraient faire
quelque chose d'autre.
En disant que ils sont là,
ils jouent comme une forme d’évitement.
C'est-à-dire, peut-être que
leur corps n'y est plus
et ils devraient faire autre chose.
Mais secrètement ils craignent
ne pas être à la hauteur.
Donc, ils continuent à jouer.
Il y a quelques uns, comme moi,
par exemple, qui jouent,
ou qui font ce qu'on fait,
comme une forme de poursuite
sur les traces de quelqu'un d'autre
qu'on admire pour gagner
son admiration ou son affection.
C'était d'ailleurs mon cas au départ
et vis à vis, mon père. »
Voilà.
À un certain moment, il m'a dit :
« Moi, j'ai transité
par tous ces genres d'émotions.
Et à la fin, chaque fois que je me rendais
compte que j'étais à un certain niveau,
je m’efforçais pour aller de l'avant.
Donc, j'ai transité par tout ça,
et aujourd'hui, je joue parce qu'un jour -
je me souviens très bien,
quand j'étais enfant -
je suis allé à un concert
dont je suis reparti complètement changé
à cause d'une note que j'ai entendue.
Ça m'a changé complètement la vie
et c'est pour ça que je joue le saxophone.
Donc aujourd'hui, je suis arrivé
au niveau de compassion
et c'est ça
l'émotion qui me fait jouer.
Et donc, pour moi,
ce que j'essaye de faire
c'est de jouer pour transformer.
Parce que dans n'importe quelle foule,
n'importe quel jour,
il y a au moins une personne
prête à être changée
et je prie pour que
cette personne soit là,
et pour qu'elle reparte changée. »
Voilà.
À ce moment-là, j'ai commencé donc
à me poser donc cette question.
Et peut-être que vous pourriez
dans ce que vous faites,
la vous poser aussi.
Je ne suis pas là pour
vous donner des conseils,
mais quelques suggestions, peut-être.
Et les questions sont les suivantes :
Pourquoi faites-vous ce que vous faites ?
Il faut répondre à cette question
de manière très honnête.
Et qu'est-ce qui vous motive vraiment ?
À la fin, si vous trouvez que l'émotion
n'est pas la bonne,
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez faire
pour en sortir
et peut-être passer
à une émotion différente ?
Qui peut-être vous donnera l'envie
ou l’énergie
de faire les choses que vous faites
à partir d'une émotion différente
qui vous dépasse et qui n'est pas
totalement centrée sur soi-même.
Et à la fin, pour qui jouez-vous ?
Parce que comme interprète,
on se souvient très souvent du fait
que chaque fois qu'on est auto-centré,
si parfois je perds une phrase,
je me punis à cause de ça,
je perds aussi la suivante.
Si je me donne
des applaudissements
parce que, oui,
j'ai bien compris ça, bien fait,
je perds aussi ce qui vient après.
Donc, on a appris comme interprète
que pour bien faire ce métier,
il faut se dépasser et donc centrer
votre attention sur quelqu'un d'autre.
Peut-être qu'il vous faut trouver
quelqu'un d'autre sur qui vous concentrer
pour mieux faire votre boulot.
Alors, ce sont deux questions difficiles
et les réponses pourraient vous échapper
pendant un certain temps.
Mais les poser, et agir en fonction
de vos intuitions qui en découlent,
c'est le seul moyen
de continuer de l’avant.
En attendant peut-être
vous pourriez essayer
certains aspects
de la routine de Vido Santiago.
C'est-à-dire prendre une petite minute
pour vous rappeler exactement
la vraie raison de votre présence
dans votre métier ou ailleurs.
Au-delà, de la cabine d’interprétation
ou de la scène,
il y a tant de découvertes à faire,
des rêves à matérialiser,
des mythes sur le point de tomber.
Tout ce qu'il faut c'est de jouer
une note précisément avec émotion
ou de prononcer un mot
avec compassion et de manière précise.
Et chaque jour,
dans n'importe quelle foule,
il y a au moins une personne
prête à être changée.
J'espère que cette personne
est à l'écoute aujourd’hui.
J'espère que vous êtes cette personne.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)